ja willkommen zu diesem Vortrag Didaktik
des metaversums das Internet als
grenzüberschreitender lehr- und Lernraum
neues Thema Metaversum man spricht oft
davon aber niemand weiß irgendwie genau
was es ist und mein Ziel in diesem
Vortrag besteht darin mal diesem Begriff
des metaversums ein bisschen zu klären
auch wenn mir das sicherlich nicht
perfekt gelingen wird und mal zu fragen
inwiefern sich das Metaversum als ein
lehr- und Lernraum verstehen lässt der
auch so Grenzüberschreitungen im
positiven Sinn jetzt ermöglicht die
Gliederung ist ich will erstmal das
Internet ein bisschen untersuchen und
zwar nicht nur als
Informationsmedium so versteht man
häufig immer noch das Internet ich werde
auch ein paar Statistiken bringen von
der Internetnutzung sondern ich möchte
anderen Fokus aufs Internet werfen
nämlich als ein Handlungsraum und ein
Wissensraum komme auch wieder zum Thema
lehr- und Lernräume unser Vergangenes
Thema des Investitions dann will ich die
Frage erörtern was ist überhaupt das
Metaversum da gibt es verschiedene
Auffassungen dazu vor allem natürlich
die von Facebook Meta diesen
kommerziellen Unternehmen da werde ich
mich ein bisschen davon abgrenzen und
eine andere Definition im Sinne von dem
Web 3.0 geben da sage ich aber auch noch
was dazu dann will ich den Begriff der
virtuellen Realität diskutieren als
Philosoph muss man ja immer auch
Begriffe versuchen zu kritisieren und zu
prägen und dann gehe ich auf die Frage
ein wie grenzüberschreitendes lernen im
Metaversum aussehen könnte und wie
Grinsen beschreiben das Lehren im
Metaversum aussehen könnte sind alles
Vorschläge und darüber können wir
natürlich dann sehr gern diskutieren ja
als erstes zum Internet sie haben alle
schon mal gehört Web 1.0 Web 2.0 und
jetzt soll es auch noch Web 3.0 geben
was ist es eigentlich also ich habe mich
da mal ein bisschen schlau gemacht auf
Wikipedia und habe eigene Gedanken noch
dazu beigetragen also Web 1 alles so
ungefähr der Zeitraum von 1991 bis 2004
es waren statische Webseiten wo die
Nutzerinnen und Nutzer eigentlich nur
Konsumenten waren also man hat praktisch
die Seite aufgerufen und es war dann so
eine Art digitale Visitenkarte sie
können bei einem archive.org dem webad
heißt können Sie mal nachschauen wie der
Spiegel die Homepage vom Spiegel im Jahr
1996 aussah da lachen wir heute drüber
das war einfach nur eine digitale
Visitenkarte da gab es keine Interaktion
paar Informationen aber eher so eine
Internetpräsenz dass man einfach auch im
Internet ist es wird Punkt 2.0 basiert
auf der Idee von Web als Plattform auch
als soziale Plattform und es erlaubt
viel mehr Interaktion der Nutzerinnen
und Nutzer also nicht mehr nur wie bei
Web 1.0 wir schauen uns eine
Visitenkarte an sondern wir laden selbst
was hoch und das beste Beispiel ist
dafür vielleicht Youtube das Motto
lautet dass man selbst nicht nur im
rezipiert sondern auch produziert und
zwar broadcast yourself das ist so das
entscheidende sobald wir uns auf Youtube
ein Konto zulegen werden wir eigentlich
schon zu kleinen Produzentin und
Produzenten und diese Interaktivität die
Nutzenden selbst mit einbezieht das ist
das Charakteristikum von Web 2.0 und Web
3.0 ist jetzt dagegen noch stärker
dezentralisiert das heißt es hängt jetzt
nicht mehr so sehr ab von den Big
Playern wie Facebook Alphabet Google und
Meta und wie sie alle heißen sondern die
individuellen Nutzen sind bekommen wir
viel größere Bedeutung und das ist die
Idee der Dezentralität und diese Idee
soll durch die Technologie der
blockchain realisiert werden blockchain
dann mache ich dann oben im Video
hinterher noch einen Link rein wer sich
dafür genauer interessiert kann sich das
anschauen also Stichwort
Dezentralisierung weitere
Autonomisierung der individuellen Person
ist so das Stichwort für das met
jetzt möchte ich mal auf das Nutzer
Verhalten eingehen was machen wir
eigentlich im Internet die meiste Zeit
und es sieht ziemlich banal aus 90%
Senden und Empfangen von E-Mails suchen
nach Informationen über Waren und
Dienstleistungen Lesen von
online-nachrichtenzeitung Suche nach
Informationen das ist ja hier wie oben
nach waren Dienstleistung dann wird es
in meinen Augen erst wirklich
interessant nämlich telefonieren
Videotelefonate bekam also auch sowas
was wir gerade machen sondern suchen
Veranstaltungen und Musik hören
vielleicht auch Youtube Videos selbst
hochladen wir sehen also das
Nutzerverhalten ist nur recht
konservativ wir sind hier noch auf der
Ebene von Web 2.0 manchmal vielleicht
auch nur auf die Ebene von Web 1.0 muss
ich sagen das heißt diese Punkte hier
Videotelefonate interaktive Gehalte die
werden in Zukunft noch mehr an Bedeutung
gewinnen aber wir sind da noch lange
nicht weil wir drei Punkten und deswegen
ist alles was ich jetzt sage auch ein
bisschen
relativ
qualist Statista ja es gibt schon einige
Untersuchungen über die Soziologie des
Internets Manuel Castells hat ein Buch
geschrieben die internetgalaxie und er
schreibt hier das Internet ist das
Gewebe auf dem unser Leben beruht es
besitzt die Fähigkeit die Kraft der
Information über den gesamten Bereich
menschliche Tätigkeit zu verbreiten das
finde ich eine sehr treffende Bemerkung
des Internet ist nicht nur so ein
statisches Abruf Medium sondern es ist
ein Medium was unseren gesamten Alltag
immer mehr betrifft wir schauen ständig
ins Internet wir bekommen Nachrichten
per Push Notification die Entwicklung
des Smartphones ist ganz ganz wichtig er
sagt auch noch das Internet wurde aus
einer anfänglichen obskuren Technologie
ohne viel Anwendungsmöglichkeiten zum
Hebel für den Übergang zu einer neuen
Gesellschaftsform zum
Netzwerkgesellschaft jetzt kann man sich
fragen wie müssen Lehren und Lernen im
Rahmen der Netzwerkgesellschaft gesehen
und dazu haben sie jetzt einige
Philosophen Gedanken gemacht allen voran
Hubert reifuß das ist ein kalifornischer
Philosoph der vor einigen Jahren
verstorben ist und der hat sich sehr
sehr kritisch dem Cyberspace zugewendet
also der Idee von Web 2.0 oder eher Web
3.0 auch am Beispiel dieses
Online-Spiels Second Life und zwar
schreibt ihr er dass wir ganz wichtige
Vermögen kapazities verlieren wenn wir
uns nur im virtuellen Raum aufhalten wir
verlieren unseren Sinn zwischen dem
wirklich wichtigen und irrelevanten zu
unterscheiden und auch dass wir das
Lernen
verlernen und auch nicht mehr ein
wirklichen Realitätsbezug herstellen
können warum weil wir unseren Körper
nicht mehr haben wir haben das
besprochen schon in der Diskussion über
einen möglichen virtuellen ein
virtuelles uno-planspiel da war das
Argument wir sind nicht mehr körperlich
da wir können auch bestimmte Gesten
nicht mehr sehen und das kritisiert
jetzt Hubert drei Fuß an diesen Idee von
Web 3.0 an Metapher sind dass wir
praktisch die Realität verlieren ein
Realitätsbezug verlieren das möchte ich
jetzt den folgenden problematisieren und
auch auf das leeren und lernen beziehen
weitere wichtige Begriff im Zentrum
dieses metaversums ist der das onlife
Luciano floridi die vierte Revolution
was waren die vorangegangenen Revolution
sie waren am kopernikanische Revolution
die darwinische Revolution und die
Freude Revolution und floridis sagt wir
haben sie mit einem ganz neuen Phänomen
zu tun was wirklich eine Revolution ist
nämlich die digitale Online-Welt faltet
sich in die analoge Offline-Welt hinein
aus und verschmilzt mit ihr da haben wir
es mit einer ganz typischen
Grenzüberschreitung sogar
grenzverschmelzung zu tun und sehr
treffen finde ich den Begriff wir leben
immer mehr an online wir sind also nicht
nur online
oder offline sind online das Leben wird
durch die Digitalisierung durchs in den
vollständig durchdrungen und wenn es so
ist ich glaube es ist so müssen uns
fragen was das für das leeren und lernen
in der Zukunft bedeuten kann also in
Zukunft wird der Unterschied zwischen
Online und Offline immer weiter
verwischen das ist die
Grenzüberschreitung auf die Fluoride
hier aufmerksam macht und besonders die
Generation Z sagte er kam on live zur
Welt ob das stimmt muss man kritisch
fragen aber es wird auf jeden Fall viel
alltäglicher weißkosten günstiger ist
und schneller und weiter verbreitet ist
das Internet so jetzt komme ich kurz
aufs mit der wersum zu sprechen auch das
ist ein Zitat aus Wikipedia und zwar
möchte ich hier anknüpfen auf die Werb
den Werbeslogan von Meta also Facebook
im Metaversum können User die Welt
mitgestalten und dort leben lernen
arbeiten und feiern wir können da
praktisch alles machen was wir auch im
analogen Leben machen können besonders
interessant finde ich das hier auf
lernen Hinweis ja das können wir jetzt
muss ich aber eine kritische einen
kritischen Einwand bringen weil wenn wir
das Web 3.0 verstehen als ein
dezentrales System was nicht mehr im
einzelnen Zentren hängt Stichwort
blockchain wenn es so verstehen dann ist
Facebook Meta oder Horizon worlds wie
die ganzen Spiele heißen eigentlich
streng genommen nicht das Metaversum
warum weil es immer noch zentral von
einem einzelnen Unternehmen abhängt also
die Idee des dead zentralen wird durch
Facebook mit der gerade nicht realisiert
das wird wieder viel zentraler und
deswegen möchte ich hier so ein bisschen
kritischen Einwand bringen das
Metaversum was uns da Facebook Meta
verkaufen möchte ist eigentlich kein
richtiges metavers da fehlt die Idee des
dezentralen
Meta wird für das Metaversum mit
folgendem Slogan das Metaversum mag nur
virtuell sein aber es wird einen realen
Einfluss haben jetzt habe ich eine Frage
sind Realität und Virtualität wirklich
Gegensätze hier ist es virtuelle nur
virtuell im Gegensatz zu Realität ich
möchte es ein bisschen Frage stellen
meine These ist auch in virtuellen
Welten können wir wirklich lernen können
wir Realitäten begegnen ich habe hier
mal eine Umfrage gemacht vor in einem
dieser Symposien habe mal die
Zuschauerin Zuschauer gefragt was
assoziieren sie mit virtueller Realität
und raus kam diese Begriffswolke und ich
hebe mal ein paar besonders wichtige
Begriffe heraus Simulation
dann haben wir noch nicht echte Realität
nur virtuell bei Meta in der Werbung
Fake dann die Brillen die man auf hat
ist ja alles nur Simulation und dann
Widerspruch warum Widerspruch naja wenn
virtuelle Realität mit virtuell falsch
ist oder nur Illusion oder Fake ist dann
ist natürlich der Begriff virtuelle
Realitäten Widerspruch also praktisch
eine Fake Realität aber es kann doch
nicht Realität sein und das finde ich
alles sehr treffend und wir müssen uns
jetzt schauen was ist jetzt eigentlich
virtuelle Realität David Chambers ein
bekannter Philosoph hat ein Buch
geschrieben über reality plus virtual
worlds and the problems of Philosophie
und er hat hier ein sehr interessanten
Comic gezeichnet als Skizze die soll die
platonische Höhle alle kennen sicherlich
das platonische Höhlengleichnis das
bezeichnet die platonische Höhle im 21
Jahrhundert also die Leute sitzen hier
auf einer Wand und bekommen hier auf die
Augen mit dieser via Brille eine
Illusion oder eine Simulation drauf ist
das wirklich virtuelle Realität das wäre
ja nur
Illusionen scheint das heißt wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir nicht einer digitalen
Unmündigkeit erliegen dass wir im
Metaversum durch die Digitalisierung nur
Illusionen vorgegaukelt bekommen nur
Scheinwelten das hat ja mit der Realität
da nichts mehr zu tun hier wird von
einem Auto sehr zurecht die Filter
Bubble auch betont das ist das Problem
dass durch die neuen Medien durch Google
durch KI für jeden Nutzer jedem Nutzerin
ein eigenes
informationsuniversum gestaltet wird
indem wir praktisch Realität von Schein
nicht mehr unterscheiden können man hält
die Information die in die Filter Bubble
gelangt von neutralobjektiv und wahr es
ist aber nicht so sondern die Bubble ist
auf unser individuelles Nutzerverhalten
und Suchverhalten zugeschnitten und das
nenne ich digitale Unmündigkeit und da
müssen wir eben auch durch Lehren und
Lernen herausfinden aus dieser
Unmündigkeit wie kann jetzt lernen im
Metaversum Aussehen ich habe schon
gesagt das metaverso sollten wir als ein
Wissensraum verstehen aber nicht als
eine der einfach vorliegt sondern der
von uns selbst offen gehalten werden
muss und zwar dass wir nicht Gefahr
laufen eine Filter Bubble zu geraten wir
können Metaversum verschiedene Rollen
annehmen und durch individualisierte
Avatare auch Pseudonym interagieren das
ist jetzt erstmal
neutral zu verstehen wir können aber
dadurch dass wir verschiedene Rollen
einnehmen können auch unser Wissen und
uns selbst unter den Gesichtspunkten von
Fiktion also ein fiktiver Charakter von
Illusion ich täusche etwas vor wenn
Simulation ich mache etwas nach und von
Realität ich mache etwas wirklich
nämlich virtuell reflektieren und das
scheint mir auch didaktisch ganz zentral
zu sein wir lernen mit perversum also
nicht nur objektives Wissen was
vorgegeben wird sondern wir modulieren
wir reflektieren dieses Wissen indem wir
es von Illusion Fiktion und Simulation
unterscheiden wir haben also ein viel
breiteren Blick auf Wissen immer unter
dem Gesichtspunkt von möglichen so ein
Fiktion und Simulation das macht das
Wissen noch viel komplexer wir können
natürlich auch durch Illusion und
Fiktion und Simulation lernen weil wir
uns neu ausprobieren können neue
Erfahrungen machen können durch diese
virtuelle Realität im metaversen werden
auch die Grenzen zwischen Arbeit lernen
und spielen überschritten das darauf hat
Meta sehr zurecht hingewiesen wenn das
Metaversum unseren Alltag betrifft dann
werden wir immer wieder auch spielen die
das Moment des Gamification ist ganz
zentral für das Internet aber es ist
eben nicht nur spielen sondern eben
spielen können wir auch lernen wir
können uns im wissensräume einklinken im
Metaversum müssen aber darauf aufpassen
dass das nicht bloße filterblasen sind
und das ist auch eine kritische
Kompetenz die wir lernen müssen indem
wir in virtuellen wissensräumen lernen
die keine filterblasen sind tragen wir
auch zu Vergrößerung dieser wissensräume
bei indem er nämlich Informationen
sinnvoll miteinander vernetzen das
Vernetzen gerade super sexuelle
vernetzen scheint mir ganz wichtig zu
sein für das Lernen im virtuellen Raum
es kann mich zum Schluss noch auf das
Leeren im wetterversum wir können
dadurch im Metaversum lehren dass wir
dezentralen lernen und Wissens von
konzipieren eröffnen und offen halten
ganz wichtig ist sie das dezentrale als
die Lehrende Person sollte so die Idee
des metaversums nicht mehr als ein
Zentrum
da stehen sondern sollte die sollte
versuchen das dezentral zu organisieren
Stichwort Autonomie der einzelnen
Lernenden wir sind Raum zeitlich als
Lehrende Person nicht von den Lehrenden
mehr so streng verschieben ja das bringt
uns alles viel mehr aneinander weil wir
nicht mehr körperlich dort existieren
und können uns auch selbst in die
einzelnen Lernprozesse einklinken das
ist also die Lehrenden von großer
Vorteil diese Nähe diese reibungslose
Nähe jetzt dann Lernenden nee und
Distanz was ja auch immer mit Grenzen zu
tun hat die erhalten kann eine ganz neue
Bedeutung zentimeterversum im Sinne der
Verbindung und Trennung von
Informationen und lernen ist über große
raumzeitliche Distanzen möglich ja wir
können praktisch mit Leuten aus der
ganzen Welt leeren und lernen das ist
die raumzeitliche Grenzüberschreitung
nicht nur das Lernen sondern auch des
Lehren wird im Metaversum dezentraler
wir können es verteilen es hängt nicht
mehr in einzelnen Instanzen trotz der
Dezentralisierung Automatisierung muss
der Lehrende den gesamten lehr- und
Lernraum überblicken und immer die
Verantwortung dafür tragen dass er nicht
zu einer Blase wird das scheint mir ganz
ganz wichtig zu sein ja vielen Dank für
die Aufmerksamkeit ich bin jetzt
gespannt auf die Diskussion